GOOD MORNING OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE FOR
THIRTY MAIENSCHEIN
THE SURPLUS COLD WAR
PLEASE ADVISE AUDIO VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BE MADE AS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED THIS CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO FLORA GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RIVAS
YEAH WICKS HERE HELLO WE HAVE
ACCORDING TO HIM AND SENATE
JENNA IS MOSTLY BECAUSE IT IS A
MOVE BY MS QUIRK SILVA SAYING
ABOUT MR MATHIS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MAN CENTER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY AYE
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
MAR I AGREE SEN GRAYSON AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE KAMLAGER-DOVE
AYE MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE AYE
QUIRK SILVA SO FAR I RAMOS
RAMOS AYE RIVAS RIVAS AYE WORKS
RIGHT WORK SIDE THAT MEASURE
IS PASSED AND -- THIS IS WHAT
IS YOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH